news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
during a senate hearing on wednesday
republican senator mike lee
i guess recovered from coronavirus said
fact-checking is a form of censorship
this is one of the guys who loves
wearing no mask he caught coronavirus he
went to a senate hearing didn't wear a
mask
despite having been diagnosed with the
virus just days earlier
complete total clown show on wednesday
there was a hearing held with the ceos
of twitter facebook and google
the topic was section 230 as you know
donald trump has been talking about
repeal section 230.
it relates to a legal responsibility to
social media companies for the content
that's published
but what it led to was a lot of
republicans going mask
off not just liter not just literally
but also mask off
figuratively here's mike lee saying fact
checking is a form of censorship
uh and when i use the word sensor here i
i mean uh
i mean block content fact check uh or
label content
or uh demonetized websites fact checking
labeling something not trustworthy
saying something is untrue
it is all censorship to mike lee so let
me
sort of interpret this for you in
realistic terms
when your entire view is based on
falsehoods and your entire political
movement is based on lying to people in
order to get them to vote for you
yeah fact checking is a problem for you
but it's not censorship
if i say for example mike lee
perpetrated
the non-existent bowling green massacre
remember when uh
kellyanne conway made up the bowling
green massacre
if i say mike lee perpetrated that if i
get
fact checked is that censorship
of course not and ted cruz at the
hearing stated
sort of uh uh he started going in the
same direction
really really dangerous now because you
are seeing more and more of the
republican party push this idea
republicans don't actually believe in
freedom of speech even though they claim
to be
the stalwart defenders of the
constitution
they just want to be free to lie to you
without anything
making it tougher for them to convince
you of those lies
and in this case the republican party
wants to
understand what they're saying legally
force private businesses whose rights
normally they defend
they want to force private businesses
like facebook and twitter to allow them
to lie to you with no consequences i
thought they were
about deregulating business i thought
they were about getting government
out of the business of private industry
so to them
every time someone interrupts their lies
with reality
we are infringing on their right to be
ignorant of reality
this is the delusional backwards
perspective that they bring to the table
on this issue now
as far as section 230 is concerned
i don't know i mean this is a bigger
topic but
if you repeal section 230
you would probably see at least some of
these social media companies
be stricter police officers
so to speak of what is published to
their platforms
because they would be more cautious
about possibly having consequences
themselves
about untrue or defamatory information
being posted by
individuals on their platform so this is
a bigger topic and and
you know after the election uh when
things hopefully calm down
we'll have actual maybe intellectual
property attorneys on to talk about it
but there's
actually a chance that repealing section
230 which trump has been talking about
may not be so good for the republican
lies that they are looking to spread
uh un unfettered for lack of a better
term but that's a bigger conversation
which we will we will certainly have let
me know your thoughts i'm on twitter at
d
pacman later today i will be addressing
a few
there have been some questions that a
lot of people have been asking me one is
david you criticized trump a lot on
kovid
but what would biden what should biden
have done differently i will address
that
i've been getting messages from people
saying david election day is it
why should ballots be counted after
election day well if they've been
sent by election day they should be
counted and i will get into that a
little bit later today
uh and i will also take some of your
calls via discord
davidpakman.com discord that's
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
great program the last friday show
before the election